lever la main ceux d'entre vous qui se
soucie notre environnement ce qui prend
l'importance de prendre soin de nos
forêts de nos lacs et de notre ère la
villa mais pourquoi la majorité d'entre
des adolescents est si présent sont-ils
conscientiser informés et soucieux de
faire leur part pour notre environnement
parce que dès la maternelle on vous en a
parlé on vous expliquer la nécessité de
ne pas pas lui et préserver nos
ressources et on l'a tellement bien fait
qu'aujourd'hui c'est vous qui gronde et
les adultes inconscients
qu'arriverait-il alors si à l'école
primaire et au secondaire nous parler
aux jeunes de façon appropriée à leur
âge de schizophrénie de maladie
bipolaire de dépression de troubles de
l'anxiété et d'autres maladies mentales
chaque être humain naît avec une flamme
intérieure une passion pour la vie qu'il
pousse à aller de l'avant à relever les
défis du quotidien et à poursuivre ses
rêves pour certains leur flamme
intérieure ressemble à ceci pour
d'autres ça ressemble plutôt à cela dans
mon cas voici ce que j'ai reçu jusqu'à
l'âge de 12
j'étais une enfant naturellement fiers
déterminée et fonceuse jeu mordait à
belles dents dans la vie puis subitement
ma vie a basculé
ma mère cette super women directeur de
banque avec treize employés à sa charge
a sombré dans une dépression majeure
sévère qui a duré six longues années
un matin elle est partie au travail
comme à l'habitude depuis longtemps elle
vivait une tristesse et une fatigue
intérieur indescriptible mais ça
personne ne le savait chaque jour s
convaincu de continuer que d'ici peu les
choses se placerait que tout irait mieux
puis sans crier gare
l'élastique a éclaté en rentrant du
travail
son cerveau cet ordinateur qui contrôle
tout son corps s'est mis à ma mère s'est
mise au lit pour ne s'en relever que un
mois plus tard celle qui menait un
bureau de finances sur ses épaules
n'arrivait plus à faire des phrases
complètes ni à lire ni même à
additionner 2 + 2 sur une calculatrice
faire un repas était une tâche trop
compliqué et celle qu'on surnommait
madame blanche ville regarder
passivement la poussière s'accumule et
voir ma mère si fortes se transformer du
jour au lendemain et un spectacle auquel
je ne m'attendais pas je croyais que ma
mère était infaillible qu'elle savait
tout et qu'elle pouvait tout régler en
criant ciseau dans la tête d'adolescente
je me suis demandé qu'est ce qui se
passe qu'est ce qu'elle a
quand va-t-elle redevenir celle d'avant
les mois puis les années passées par
maman ma mère ne se lever plus de matane
pour déjeuner avec moi elle n'avait
aucune idée si j'avais de l'argent ou au
lodge pour le dîner mes résultats
scolaires ne l'intéressé plus jalouse et
secrètement mes amis qui me racontaient
leurs activités leurs sorties familiales
parce que chez moi
on sortait plus il ya quelques occasions
lorsque j'ai participé à un spectacle à
l'école il n'y avait personne dans les
gradins pour me soutenir et m'encourager
je savais que ma mère était malade
on m'avait même dit qu'elle faisait une
dépression mais personne ne m'en
expliquer les ravages intérieur que
cause cette maladie en tant
qu'adolescente tout ce que je voyais
c'est que ma mère ne s'intéressait plus
à moi une foule de questions hantent et
mon esprit
ma mère et elle fâchée contre moi que
puis-je faire pour la faire sourire à
nouveau
pour retrouver l'attention de ma mère
j'ai d'abord essayé la perfection
peut-être qu'en cumulant des as sur mon
bulletin
peut-être qu'en gagnant des médailles
dans les sports peut-être qu'en
remportant des concours je réussirai à
rendre ma mère fière et qu'elle me
verrai à nouveau car j'avais
l'impression de ne plus exister
cette belle flamme qui me caractérise
est grillé de moins en moins fort
malheureusement malgré mes efforts
malgré mes réussites
rien n'a changé j'ai alors opté pour une
stratégie différente
j'ai consommé de l'alcool j'évolue dans
les magasins et j'ai même avalé les
antidépresseurs de ma mère à part
augmenter l'anxiété de ma mère
rien n'a changé à quoi bon continuer
d'essayer
il ne me restait plus qu'une seule
solution me détacher faire comme si ma
mère n'existait plus je suis entré dans
l'âge adulte le coeur brisé et
l'impression d'être seuls au monde d'une
façon inconsciente
j'avais intériorisé un discours qui
disait ce n'en vaut pas la peine
pendant des années j'ai travaillé sur
moi en lisant des livres sur le
développement personnel et surtout en
écrivant dans mon journal intime
selon l'endroit où je tentais de faire
du sens de ce que j'avais vécu en tant
qu'adolescente et aussi de me bâtir en
tant qu'adulte
mais la vie est merveilleuse par un
hasard du destin
vers l'âge de 28 ans je suis devenu
représentant de pharmaceutique dans le
domaine de la psychiatrie
j'ai assisté à des formations et pour la
première fois je comprenais mieux ce que
ma mère avait vécu je comprenais enfin
que si ma mère ne s'était pas occupé de
moi c'est parce qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
et non parce qu'il ne voulait pas ma
flamme intérieure a aussitôt repris de
la vigueur
un autre hasard du destin a complètement
changé ma façon de voir mon adolescence
une amie à moi dans la jeune trentaine
étaient hospitalisées à cause d'un
épisode de maladie mentale sévère
lorsque je les visite est recroquevillée
sur son lit d'hôpital j'ai pu lire sa
souffrance intérieure sur son visage
elle me répétait sans cesse
julie je dois aller mieux pour mes
filles je dois aller mieux pour mes
filles
cette journée là j'ai compris que ce qui
a permis à ma mère de tenir bon sa
motivation première
avec cette douleur incommensurable qui
l'habitait c'est l'amour qu'elle voit à
ses enfants
c'est pour nous qu'elle s'est battue
jusqu'au bout c'est pour nous qu'elle a
enduré la douleur et que la sucent
s'accrocher à l'espoir
il n'en fallait pas plus pour que je
retrouve la vitalité ma flamme
intérieure j'étais redevenu celle
d'avant et j'étais déterminé à faire une
différence dans la vie de jeunes qui
vivent des situations similaires
mon premier pas en ce sens c'est un
livre que j'ai publié en 2013
inspiré d'une histoire vraie il raconte
la vie d'une adolescente vivant auprès
d'une mère schizophrène il est un
message d'espoir et de résilience est
aussi une façon de démystifier et
d'expliquer la maladie mentale aux
jeunes
qu'y at-il à retenir de mon histoire
c'est très simple parce qu'on ne m'a pas
expliqué ce qui se passait je me suis
imaginé que la maladie de ma mère était
peut-être de ma faute que ma mère ne
s'intéressait pas à moi et qu'elle ne
m'aimait pas alors qu'en réalité ma mère
mener la bataille de sa vie contre une
maladie sournoise que serait-il arrivé
si on m'avait dit julie thomert
souffrent beaucoup
c'est une maladie et cela n'a rien à
voir avec toi si elle ne s'occupe pas
toi c'est qu'elle n'en est pas capable
à cause de la maladie tamer fait tout ce
qu'elle peut pour s'en sortir il existe
des traitements et bientôt elle ira
mieux
aurais-je vécu de la compassion envers
ma mort au lieu de la colère aurais-je
intériorisé un discours plus sain envers
moi même
on dit que 20% de la population et
prouvera au cours de sa vie un épisode
de maladie mentale
un enfant à 2 par an donc dans cette
salle de 300 adolescents
c'est jusqu'à 120 d'entre vous qui
pourriez vivre avec un parent ou un
proche en difficulté c'est énorme
dès que professionnels de la santé
rencontre parents atteints de maladie
mentale
il devrait être obligatoire que ce
professionnel propose une rencontre avec
les enfants pour leur expliquer la
situation
le conjoint et dès que possible par an
atteint devrait recevoir un coaching 5
sur comment aborder le sujet avec les
enfants et comment les sécuriser dès
l'école primaire tous les jeunes
devraient être sensibilisés à la maladie
mentale afin de leur apprendre à voir la
personne derrière la maladie pour que
les jeunes comprennent mieux la maladie
mentale de leurs parents pour préserver
la flamme intérieure de ceux qui vivent
de telles situations pour bâtir une
société de demain
conscientiser informés et abolir les
tabous et les jugements entourant la
maladie mentale
nous devons démystifier et expliquer la
maladie mentale aux jeunes j'imagine un
monde où la maladie mentale n'existe pas
d'ici là parlons-en
merci